hey it's kind of Elliott with Bloomberg
pursuits and we're here with the new
Ferrari 488 GTB today in Geneva Ferrari
in veiled what I consider to be the most
beautiful car of the show the 488 GTB
can you see how lovely the lines on this
are the curve of the nose as it rounds
toward the hips and the delicately
sculpted body as it opens two air vents
along the side there's a reason vintage
Ferraris go for millions of dollars at
auction these days they're gorgeous and
this car unmistakably follows that path
in fact even though the 488 GTB is
completely new with a new style and new
engine derived from Formula One racing
technology you can see the straight line
at the design heritage from the 308 GTB
Ferrari made in 1975 to the Athletics
supercar we see today and boy is this
thing athletic
it's a 670 horsepower coupe with a
rear-engine v8 and a 0 to 60 miles per
hour sprint time of 3 seconds flat did I
mention it's got 100 horsepower more
than the Ferrari 458 top speed is 205
miles per hour most notable for purists
at least is the fact that this is the
first Ferrari in decades to use a
turbocharged engine engineers often use
a turbo to increase efficiency but
sometimes those Chargers are accused of
lagging response times and if not
selling as raw as their naturally
aspirated counterparts but in fact
Ferrari assures us the company was
obsessive about maintaining a distinct
sound an instantaneous response with the
new 488 GTB well I haven't driven it yet
but from the looks of it we have nothing
to worry about
fingers crossed this has been Hannah
Elliot with Bloomberg
and we've seen the new Ferrari 488 GTB